now texas senator ted cruz is continuing
and rightly demanding transparency from
the bite administration
he's demanding full access to these
overwhelm migrant facilities following
his recent border trip
where he saw all the inhumane conditions
hand
as we showed you earlier senator cruz
today released this video
documenting that trip highlighting just
what a security and humanitarian crisis
joe biden created at our border and of
course
a covert super spreader of all super
spreaders take a look
we're down in the southwest border in
the rio grande valley
and we are seeing children and families
who are suffering
as a result of political decisions joe
biden made
joining us now with reaction texas
senator ted cruz center first i applaud
you
ron johnson tom cotton lindsey graham
there were 18 of you
thank you for doing what you did and you
would not be intimidated
when one of i guess somebody worked for
joe biden's administration
tried to demand you stop filming why
don't you in your own words tell america
what you saw and what we're looking at
well so last thursday and friday i
brought a group of 19 senators down to
the border in texas to the rio grande
valley
we started the trip thursday night by
joining the the border patrol agents for
their 10 pm muster all of us took the
chance to tell them
thank you particularly at a time when
they're not getting the support from
their political superiors i think it was
important for them to know that we love
them and we're grateful for the
bravery they show every day we then
joined them on their midnight patrol we
went out
we encountered caravans of illegal
immigrants
walking up the trails coming north from
the rio grande
river we saw little kids walking some of
them walking alone
we saw young mothers carrying infants
and nursing them as they walked along
the trails
and they all went to the first
processing facility that
that cdp has set up it's outside it's
underneath a highway bridge
and it consists of a series of outdoor
pens where the kids and the moms were
just sitting or lying on the floor they
get processed
and they get sent through the next day
we went to where they get
sent which is the donna facility the
donna is this gigantic
tent city it is massive it was designed
to hold a thousand people
but with covid restriction its capacity
is only 250.
when we toured the donna facility there
were over 4
000 people crammed into there these are
the biden cages for four years
we heard democrats in the media
screaming about kids in cages under
donald trump what they didn't admit
is barack obama built the cages and joe
biden is building new cages and they're
bigger
and they're more full kids were packed
in there
it was at a one thousand five hundred
percent
capacity level and the covid positivity
rate in that facility is about ten
percent and there
i took a number of photographs i took a
number of videos
because the biden administration refused
to allow the media in
sean you sent a camera team down so so
that fox news would be able to film what
happened there
the biden team said no media mind you
the trump administration allowed media
in the obama administration did the
george w bush administration did the
bill clinton administration did
but not biden they desperately wanted to
cover it up
and as you noted biden did send a
political minder
a woman who said she was the senior
adviser to the commissioner of cbp
who jumped in front of my phone blocked
the shot
and and began berating senators saying
you can't take these pictures
and and i believe the american people
have a right to know what's happening
and joe biden should not have the
ability to cover it up
and hide the inhumane treatment the
public health menace he's creating
and the national security crisis his
policies
have created let me ask you a legal
question
if i if i had a facility that i was
running
for children and it looked like that
do you think i could legally be charged
with abuse of children
one number two secondly if somebody is a
is not in this country legally and i
assist them
in coming across the border into the u.s
would i be aiding and abetting in a
crime
both of those questions are very
possibly yes in terms of a facility like
this
if you had a school if you had a child
care if you had any facility that takes
care of kids
that that was even a fraction of what
the biden administration is set up you'd
be shut down
the public health authorities would go
after you you would be fined you might
even be prosecuted you know
these these cages that the kids were in
they weren't six feet apart they weren't
three feet apart they weren't even six
inches apart they were literally lying
on the floor
there are no beds there are no cots
lying on the floor
side by side touching huddled under
reflective aluminum foil emergency
blankets
this is we saw about a dozen boys that
morning who
in the middle of in the middle of a
pandemic just that morning a dozen boys
had tested positive for covid and they
keep putting him in these into an
emergency detention center and
there's one gigantic room it is the size
of
three and a half football fields so it's
massive
the entire room is nothing but cots
one after the other after the other over
2
200 cots lined up in a room three and a
half times the size of a football field
nothing but teenage boys ages 13 to 17.
this is the biden crisis he is
responsible
and the important thing to understand is
it was political decisions joe biden
made that caused this crisis three in
particular
the week he got sworn in he halted
construction of the border wall
he reinstated the failed catch and
release policy
and he ended the remain in mexico
international agreement
which had stopped this last year we had
the lowest illegal immigration in 45
years
right now today we have the highest
illegal immigration
in 20 years it was preventable and it's
joe biden's fault
senator i can't thank you enough because
they tried to they prevented the media
from going in our cameras were not
the only reason we have this video in
large part because of you sharing it
with the american people thank you for
that
and also making americans aware about it
and
and what is happening here american
people need to see and they need to lift
the gag order
on border patrol agents also senator i
thank you
it's sad but this needs to end
those policies those three policies need
to be reinstated
all right good job senator ted cruz